au secours
démonstration d'une arrestation équestre
mais vrai policiers police nationale
police municipale et pompiers étaient
présents pour faire découvrir après de
300 visiteurs les différentes facettes
du métier geste de premiers secours
démonstration de la brigade cynophile
initiation à l'escalade et à la boxe
mais aussi à la tyrolienne ils vont
équiper des enfants ou des adultes ça
peut être tout le monde tous les âges
pour pouvoir faire un parcours avec les
équipements de policiers et le temps fa
le casque et les le justaucorps pour
voir le poids
c'était un peu lourd c'est super les
deux les enfants apprennent plein de
choses là il voit comment ça se passe
une interpellation il y a plein de
stands il voit comment interviennent les
pompiers en proposant ses activités
pompiers et policiers espèrent changer
leur image auprès du public mais là
justement pour leur expliquer comment ça
se déroule pour répondre à leurs
questions et leur montrer que on peut
être aussi de très belles personnes à
travers l'uniforme aujourd'hui les
interventions de police et de pompiers
sont pas forcément tout le temps sereine
et c'est ce genre d'événements ça permet
d'avoir des échanges informels entre la
population et les policiers pompiers
dans un moment d'amusement en fait cet
événement est aussi l'occasion de
susciter des vocations policiers ça a
l'air trop bien on peut monter à cheval
on a des menottes on a un taser on a un
pistolet au cas où un événement qui
devrait se reproduire chaque année la
police nationale recrute plusieurs
centaines d'officiers
[Musique]